elle a essayé durant toute cette
prestation de fendre l'armure c'était un
meeting qu'elle ne pouvait pas rater
[Musique]
dans cette campagne
tout est permis y'a plus digne politique
ya plus de code d'honneur la trahison
est devenu à tel point banal qu'on
trouve normal qu une campagne
présidentielle se résume à une campagne
de débauchage combien d'élus monsieur
zemmour va-t-il volé à madame le pen qui
sera le prochain candidat à la gamelle
macro nien elle a essayé durant toute
cette prestation son compteur d'ailleurs
au demeurant il faut le noter de fendre
l'armure est con mais aussi un peu de
manière qu'il ya c'est à dire de sortir
de cette image policée de bon élève pour
être une candidate qui est une
combattante emmanuel macron a envoyé une
lettre aux français ils auraient dû en
même temps leur envoyer la facture la
facture du quinquennat des promesses non
tenues et réforme santé depuis janvier
je suis et vous êtes avec moi
l'adversaire à battre pour emmanuel
macron pas question de voir se relever
une droite républicaine une droite qui
défend au ces valeurs je les appelle à
la révolte contre des scénarios écrits
d'avancé
c'est une rhétorique de dénonciation
c'est une rhétorique qui veut aussi
finalement essayé de dégager une image
de sincérité parce que valérie pécresse
a été très souvent finalement critiqué
sur son manque de sincérité
il faut bien comprendre que ce meeting
vise à corriger l'image négative qui a
été celle du meeting considérée comme
ratée par nombre d'observateurs mais
aussi le d'opposants elle a plutôt
disons réussi en partie à corriger cette
image
[Musique]
elle s'est adressée directement aux
militants en essayant de les galvaniser
d'une manière qui semblait moins
artificiel lors du premier meeting on ne
peut que finalement constaté qu'il ya
d'une certaine façon un certain nombre
de progrès qui ont été effectuées durant
tout ce meeting valérie pécresse a voulu
signifier qu'elle incarnait la vraie
droit
nous sommes les seuls héritiers du
général de gaulle tout ce qui est autour
de nous prétendent mener une politique
de droite sont soit des imposteurs soit
des usurpateurs la droite emmanuel
macron marine le pen eric zemmour sont
les faussaires nous en sommes nous les
légataires elle a montré qu'elle était à
chaque faction l'héritière eux se passer
cesti gieux qu'il fallait qu'elle essaye
de retrouver stimuler une forme de
sillons face à la pression à la physique
des j'allais dire presque de ses forces
qui aujourd'hui la concurrence va
essayer de ré en racines et son chéri
port politique et qu elle pouvait rien
racines et son territoire politique en
délégitimant évidemment les concurrents
que qu'il fallait c'est une certaine
manière procéder à une sorte de
rhétorique de la publicité comparative
les autres sont des offres phares this
ce sont des gens qui nous trompent d'une
manière ou d'une autre larvée droite la
droite responsable la droite et litière
de cette histoire de droite de perdre
moi c'est moi valérie pécresse voilà à
quelles affaissement démocratique nous a
conduit la société du spectacle on peut
monter de toutes pièces comme l'a fait
eric zemmour une fausse rencontre dans
une station service
oh
on peut refuser le débat avec ses
adversaires comme l'ont fait marine le
pen où le président sortant qui de son
balcon de l'elysée regarde de haut la
démocratie
marine le pen et eric zemmour sont
l'assurance réélection des manières
macro
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un discours
d'affranchissement des reproches qu'on a
pu lui faire c'est un discours de combat
et de dénonciation de ses concurrents et
de ses adversaires et c'est un discours
qui se veut un discours de mobilisation
à quelques hectomètres du premier tour
de cette élection présidentielle
[Musique]